[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد احبطت دائره الجمارك
الاردنيه بالتعاون مع الاجهزه الامنيه
اكبر واضخم عمليه تهريب لحبوب الكبتاجون
المخدره كانت مخبئه في شاحنتين قادمتين من
الاراضي العراقيه واوضح بيان لدائره
الجمارك الاردنيه ان العاملين في مركز
الجمرك الكرامه الحدودي تمكنوا من احباطي
تهريب سته ملايين حبه من الكبتاجون المخدر
بما يعادل 1000 كلغ وجدت مخباه داخل عجينه
التمر واوضح البيان انه اثناء التفتيش
الدقيق والمعاينه لشاحنتيه براد تحمل كل
منهما لوحه اجنبيه قادمه من العراق وجدت
الحبوب المخدره الكبتاجون مخبئه بطريقه
احترافيه
اذا نناقش هذا الموضوع من بغداد معنا معنا
الجبوري المحلل السياسي ومن عمان خالد
البكار عضو مجلس الاعيان
الاردنيه مرحبا بكم
من عمان ابدا معك همم بدايه همم كيف يمكن
فهمم هذه القصه ما قصه الكبتاجون في
الاردن
ولماذا الان من العراق يتم ايقاف هذه
الشحنه الكبيره جدا من هذه الماده المخدره
نعم يسعد مساك
بدون شك يعني هذه
بادره او سابقه اليوم تتم من خلال حدود
الكرامه كما تعلم احنا من سنوات ومنذ
اندلاع الازمه السوريه ونحن الحقيقه نرفع
الصوت عاليا ونقول بانه ال- ال- الارهاب
وانهيار حمايه الحدود الامني مقلق ومكلف
على الدوله الاردنيه وكما تعلم انه خلال
الثلاث سنوات الماضيه القوات المسلحه
الاردنيه بذلت جهود غير عاديه في احباط
عشرات الحالات من تهريب حبوب الكبتاجون
وغيره همم لكن ما يلفت الانتباه هذه المره
بانه واضح ان المساله ليست مرتبطه فقط
بمساله تجاريه وانما هي مرتبطه من الواضح
بان هناك طرف اا يستفيد من خلق حاله من
البلبله وزعزعه الامن في المنطقه خاصه في
ظل همم البدء بالتفكير جديه في دول
المنطقه لبلوريت رؤيا همم ينبثق عنها حاله
من التشاركيه الاقتصاديه والامنيه من
الدول العربيه والاقليم نعم النقطه الاخرى
من الواضح انه الطرف الذي تبنى هذه
العمليه واضح ان له همم حاله من القدره او
السيطره همم على على الدولتين ولذلك يبدو
ان الاردن من سنتين غير من قواعد الاشتباك
وبدا يعني فعليا بضبط كل الحدود اللي
بتعرف الحدود فيها يعني بحدود 350 كيلو
متر تقريبا عندما ضبطت هذه الحدود واحبطت
عشرات همم العمليات من الواضح ان من يرعى
هذه العمليات من التهريب والذي لا يستهدف
فقط للسوق الاردني ويستهدف حتى دول الجوار
من الواضح انه ايضا له تاثير في
الدوله العراقيه وبدا من الواضح التسلل من
خلال تلك الحدود ليفاجئ القوات المسلحه
الاردنيه من جها ومن ثم
من العراق جدد ترحيب بيك معنا الاستاذ مع
الجبوري من يرعى عمليات نقل المخدرات الى
الاردن وكما اشار او المح ضيفه ربما الى
دول اخرى عربيه في المنطقه همم منذ بدايه
الثوره السوريه كما قال ضيفه من عمان كانت
المخدرات او الكابته هون بالتحديد تدخل من
سوريا الى الاردن الان من العراق من يرعى
عمليات همم يعني تهريب هذه المخدرات
طاب يومك استاذ صهيب واضح ان الحدود
العراقيه منذ 2003 حتى الان مشكله اساسيه
بالنسبه للامن الداخلي وبالتالي الاقليمي
هو دائما همم
نوهنا الى
الارتباك الوضع الامني في اي بلد الان لا
يمكن ان يكون همم
لوحده المتضرر اي لم تكن دول الجوار وحتى
همم ما بعدها همم بماما عن هذا همم
الخلل الامني الذي همم طبعا مساله الحدود
تشكل الجوهريه فيه نتيجه استغلالها اولا
همم
التي تحاول ان تستثمر هذا الخلل وهذا
الخلق وهذه هي الفوضى التي عامه البلاد
همم كانت
اغرادت جاريه وانا اضع الناس جانب التجاري
في المرحله الثانيه في المرتبه الثانيه
انما هناك اهداف اكثر هي همم تجمير الشباب
اللي في هذه الدوله او تلك همم محاوله
ارسال رساله لان هذه الدول ايضا ليس في
مامن عما يدور في هذا البلد او ذاك في
العراق نحن نمتلك مشكله الحدود ما اولا مع
الجانب الايراني كما هو معلوم
وكثيرا ما قياده قوات الحدود المنافذ
الحدوديه ايضا تقوم بمسك واا افشال
المحاولات ادخال هذه الحبوب ولكن ما اعتقد
ان نسبه ما يعبر الى الاراضي العراقيه
ومنه الى الدول الاخرى اكثر من الكميات
التي يتم مسكها او القاء القبض على
المدربين اولا لطول لطول الحدود بصراحه
هنا همم العراق وايران بالدرجه الاولى
ونحن نعلم ان هذه التجاره رائجه
بين العراق وايران هذا اعترف به العديد من
المسؤولين يعني في الجانب العراقي احد
القيادات في البصره
ولكن انت تقصد هنا ان هذه الحبوب التي تم
ايقافها في الاردن مصدرها همم ايران
ودخلت الى العراق ومنها الى الى الاردن ام
لا يعني من من سوريا نتحدث جرى تحويل
المسار باتجاه العراق ومنها الى الاردن
من الناحيه من الناحيه العملياتيه على
الارض استاذ صهيب سوء الحدود السوريه مع
الاردن اقرب من ان تدخل هذه يعني مرحله
جديده يعني دخول هذه التهريب هذه المخدرات
او الحبوب الى العراق
من الكيلومترات وبالتالي تخترق حدود اخرى
الى الاردن هذا يعقد المشهد يعني ليس من
المنطقه ان يتم هذا الخيار لان الاردن
اقرب الى سوريا ولكن انا لا احدد ايران
بالذات انما يعني ليس المصدر ربما ليس
ايران يعني نحن لدينا مشاكل مع تركيا ايضا
ولكن ما ما نعاني منه في العراق الان هو
مرورها كانت سوا ان تاتي من افغانستان في
افغانستان يتم صناعه المخدرات بشكل كبير
استاذ صهيب وتمر ايضا هناك تجاره رايجه من
افغانستان الى ايران الى العراق العراق
اصبح حقيقه ليس فقط اا بلدا اا للمرور
انما اصبحت مشكله نعاني منها يعني مشكله
اساسيه تعاني من ايش الحكومه العراقيه
والشعب العراقي والشباب العراقي يعاني من
هذه المشكله بشكل كبير ااا استاذ خالد في
عمان المحت قبل قليل انه يعني هي 1000 كجم
من الكبتاجون تم ايقافها على حدود الاردن
المساله ابعد من الربح التجاري كما ذكرت
همم ربما لها اهداف اخرى ما هي هذه
الاهداف يا ترى
يعني من الواضح اذا بتنظر الى مساله
التغيير يعني القضيه التجاريه بدات
بالبدايه مع الحدود مثل ما اشرت حضرتك
واشار ايضا
صديقنا من العراق بانه الحدود الشماليه
الاردنيه اللي هي الجنوبيه السوريه كانت
تهريب ياتي من تلك المنطقه ونتيجه الضغط
الحقيقه والجهود اللي بذلتها قواتنا
المسلحه استطاعت ان تضبط بس بعام 2021
بحدود ال 15 ل 16 مليون حبه كبتاجون خلال
السنه كامله هذا يعني انه المساله ليست
فقط يعني يعني مش السوق الاردني المستهدف
مش قضيه مش قضيه بس تجاريه من الواضح انه
في جزء منها همم يتم توجيهه للسوق الاردني
ومن الواضح ايضا ان هناك دول الجوار ايضا
مستهدفه يعني ان هذه الشبكه قد تمرر هذه
الحبوب من خلال الحدود وتسعى لاصاله الى
دول الجوار هذه هذه نقطه النقطه الثانيه
من الواضح نتيجه الضغط على هذه الحدود
الانتقال الى الحدود العراقيه بدلك على
انه هذه الشبكه مهمتها ليست فقط تجاريه من
الواضح ان هناك طرف في المنطقه مستفيد من
خلق الفوضى وانزلاق المنطقه في فوضى ومن
الواضح انه يعني مثل ما بتعرف بالسنتين
الاخيرتين قتلت الفوضى
كيف تخلق الفوضى
له هدفين اولا انت تشغل الاجهزه الامنيه
والقوات المسلحه بالانشلال على الحدود
والجهود المضاعفه ولذلك بده يضل كل الضغط
الان متمركز حول الحدود لضبط هذه العمليات
وعدم دخولها الى الاردن هذا من ناحيه من
ناحيه ثانيه ايضا استنفار الاجهزه الامنيه
في الداخل حتى تمنع من مرورها بثلاثه حتى
لا تصل الى دول الجوار النقطه الثالثه ما
يتم ابقائه في الاردن واشار همم صديقي
الجبوري الى استهداف الشباب العربي
احنا بنحكي بلد مثل الاردن في 68% من سكان
شباب واضح ان هناك مبادرات عربيه
الشباب العربي
من العراق فقط
ان تكون هناك اليه جماعيه عربيه يمكن
التوصل اليها لايقاف هذا الموضوع
سريعا لو سمحت
لا يمكن لدوله لا يمكن لدوله لوحدها استاذ
صهيب ان تحسم هذا الامر هناك شبكات عالميه
شبكات دوليه نحن نعلم الحدود حتى في
اوروبا فيها مشاكل هذه ارقى دول العالم في
امريكا بين امريكا والمكسيك على سبيل
المثال عجزه القوات الامريكيه يعني ان
تضبط الحدود فما بالك في بلد تعمه الفوضى
العراق
العراقيه الاردني من عمان شكرا جزيلا لكما
واا مشاهدينا الكرام شكرا لكم انتم على
كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]